to the surprise
so for they see a lot of colleagues and
scientists here a lot of you guys are
great communicators so I know near the
Titan is here and there you are
I think you
what's your take off today
spontaneous remarks let me see surely
everyone in this room I remember when my
code was being discussed and debated in
Congress and it was not clear whether it
would get funded and it took people with
great foresight to say this is something
we should begin even though the
technology isn't ready for it because
the science certainly was and that's the
kind of decision-making that I mean they
hinted to it at the beginning of this
press conference the kind of
decision-making that invents a future
for whatever is the frontier that's
being tapped by that grant money and
also just by historical reflection when
Herschel discovered planet Uranus and
not shortly and not long after that he
realized that it's work it was not
tracking what Newton's laws of gravity
would prescribe for it there was a
question about whether Newton's laws
would no longer apply at such a great
distance that had been tested for earth
and the moon and Jupiter's satellites
and this sort of thing and so there was
just a little bit of doubt and then
someone said well let's assume it works
and perhaps there's another
and sure enough the mathematics was
invoked prediction was made and
practically the same night the
assignment was given to an observer at a
telescope planet Neptune was discovered
night I mentioned this we all know this
most of us know that story but I want to
contrast that to the fact that mercury
was also misbehaving its perihelion
point was processing at a rate that
could not otherwise be explained by
newton's laws of gravity and so while
we've been down that road before a
planet misbehaving we're not going to
give up on Newton's laws clearly because
it's as if they're badass really so so
what so we so we astronomers just
invoked a missing planet orbiting very
close to the Sun you may have never
heard of this planet's whole planet
Vulcan very close to the Sun so that you
couldn't really see it okay in the glare
of the Sun people look during total
solar eclipses still didn't find it so
maybe it's behind the Sun so we gave
ourselves excuses for why we couldn't
find it but we invoked a planetary mass
whose gravity would influence mercury in
just the way we needed to process the
perihelion point 1916 would come along
and Einstein's general theory of
relativity actually showed the limits of
Newton's theories of gravity and so here
we have and explain the perihelion shift
of mercury for free ice and I did start
his day saying that was his goal and so
we dropped Vulcan at the snap of a
finger and so the point is just to share
with you some of the challenges we face
on the frontier here are two cases where
in one case it was another planet in
another case it was an entirely new
understand
the fabric of the universe and thus was
born this quest to fully flesh out what
general relativity is how it works how
can we predict it and if anyone has said
at the time of the prediction of gravity
waves so why even bother this will never
happen and yet a hundred years feels
like a lot to us in our lifetimes but
over the history of the discovery of
science it's not that long so I lay
awake at night wondering what brilliant
thoughts people might be having today
that might take another century to
reveal itself in our technologies I also
want to highlight that as Martin hora
wrote in his book which I recommend for
everyone here cosmic discovery he
explores how when and where major shifts
occur in the field of astrophysics and
he noted without hesitation that the
onset of new technologies new detectors
create abrupt leaps in the field open
entire new branches of Investigation and
this is another one of one of these
another such window to the universe that
gets open so i'm course i'm like i said
i'm delighted as is everyone here i was
actually visiting the LIGO Center in
Livingston Louisiana just a month ago
and brother they've all quite hush about
this
and I'm just stunned at the precision of
these instruments and then I was
wondering if they didn't detect gravity
ways would it be the world's best
seismometer you know and you put it to
use of that so I'm one just final
thought here general relativity
at the time and for most of the past
hundred years it been thought of mostly
as an obscure thing in the field of
physics until our gps satellites come
online and then we realize that their
elevation above Earth's surface at the
speed they're orbiting they're affected
by relativity twice won because of their
physical speed another because they're
in a different place in the Earth's
gravitational well that accounts for a
tiny correction that has to be
introduced otherwise the GPS would give
you the wrong location on Earth's
surface
drifting by 10 kilometers a day so that
in fact it's not just some obscure thing
that only you know the physicists have
to worry about it actually has practical
applications so if anyone is asking us
about general relativity tell them it
helps them how to find grandma's house
as soon as you can so I'm happy to but
just be a part of this I you know I get
asked often to reflect on discoveries
like this by the press what I've tried
to do is cultivate a relationship with
them where if they say oh can you tell
us about my god I say have you
interviewed the people who gave their
lives to this first no no you're here I
said I'm not talking to you until you
talk to these people then you can come
back to me and I'll be happy to time
board and so I'm delighted to actually
be in the boat tying of service of
science right here in New York City and
so turn the program back over to you
guys
thanks for joining us I'm really excited
that you did not say this is the end we
detected it and that's it right it's the
opening with that CPI of the Columbia
groups of America is there right now I
know he's available on skype and we are
gonna try that I'm calling him he's not
denying us and not to mention he does
not he cannot take questions right now
because he's just booked up but he's
gonna have a couple of minutes I'm
trying to reflect on us and I think he's
standing by I hope we are gonna get my
computer sounds going at one point
it is my pleasure many many students
this is beyond my loss to details really
Michael with dignity we can make it
happen in our energy today and the last
year lost you want and torture because
you
surveys but we have to be sure before we
share of this colony new today you know
that we not only prove that like you
have a serum additional ways that we can
study cosmos but we also discovered the
first binary that was systems system
this is a fairly large system with
family animals using like magnet and
this is very significant because then we
have is that for systems it is not only
a likely story it is not only an
estimate of discovery or it real really
let us study physics it will let us to
listen to the music of the cosmos in
many that that you can you can watch you
can smell you can taste you can see and
one day one day you can hear that there
is the glorious day because you can
appreciate people you can appreciate
even the smallest motion on the right
train do not would never be the same
again this is what happen to us this is
what happened to us humanity from today
we can hear the process we can see are
seen before and we can see the details
of
from my grade police on stage right now
and rather than taking the stage from
them I give you back and thank you for
coming and please congratulate to the
team they great Columbia students to
rate one year ago when I had seen that
monastery Columbia student switched on
the library tour exactly February 11 in
Hanford Washington I didn't know that
this building Warriors day I'm so happy
with my thank you very much
all right - I guess anybody can go
students with arson here in the audience
for many many years
thank you okay question maybe you was
working with a paper that paper is not
in nature it's in Peoria and
can i I have a question does the just a
little piece around
the kinetic spike it's still breaking
progress something makes it turned up to
the tree no follow up step was done on a
timely manner so that's already but we
have not seen we have seen between a
network totally keep at the same time
when they were from different directions
thank you
so is this event a pretty likely
sizeable we did a sizable strain
are
we are sensitive to depending on how far
the events that we see it to toll that
about this happen to miss these things
hurt the universe once in a while so we
have to spend that which we can see
thanks
observing 35 degrees and if we observe
for years gonna be four times more
furthermore graduation so it's a hundred
times more arrivals to be detected in a
few years per year right now the chances
over there - the expected number of
University vector is less than 1 for
this to perfection we are still behind
the dealer so this is not the first
but these were spinning fast they were
not these kids were not aligned with the
orbital plane to become weaker this
transponder what's the spectrum is the
part of this vocation s for vinegar to
clean up though of the orbiter we can
very well understand how are they spend
it's
this is really the first experimental
evidence for something like it's never
happened promise one event we can
actually compute order expectation is in
terms of it and this is this is half the
fun of it but the Concannon papers that
we published this exactly honest how
often we expect backwards so from the
slow measurement we can remember the
signal-to-noise ratio of his demands
extreme highs we can find everything
every dozen Hydra significance about an
snr knowledge falls throughout the
capitis but isn't assuming he passed in
the event which is wonderful gave their
lives much easier but the point is it
was so close
that's four times three months per year
right
use text order of a hundred more
deductions and in his first plan stove
again we may have been lucky with three
specifically but whatever we have gives
more degrees so you can see there's
again this is a discovery the first the
first this is not the results today so
there could be anything I cannot but so
again - you mystical it's a possibility
because this is not
so we need which even attached me
neither me neither
so this is what written is very smart is
the collaboration either the only
integer which have been made but we were
so happy that they did that because we
really documented the defective status
for the coming weeks
and I think so so let me about what was
really important here is that we have
algorithms that find these kind of
events within minutes of their
occurrence so it's an extremely quick
thing and one things that we do this is
to be able to look at the same events
but Costco Swift that make you defeat of
the Penguins other things but the reason
is really what Joe is saying is that we
can stop whatever we're doing and we can
make sure that's the defector conditions
are fixed so if you collect that
background so we can reclaim things like
this we were lucky there were many
engineering practices I think there's no
running eights so if this came previous
one we may have not been final to the
extent that it would have been that the
same way but this is our last any
problems was sort of a nominal thing of
that but everything meaningful was fine
- you think that testing things
faithfulness to the previous ones we're
called ingenuity so the other
congratulations this is of course very
very early days for this technology and
this is comparable to where we were with
telescopes many hundreds of years ago
and there are some nice things here with
this because the noise between different
detectors is uncorrelated but the signal
is correlated the more detectors you
have the better new tune everything the
more interesting signal you're going to
be able to pull in what are the what are
the fundamental limits on sensitivity
here how sensitive given an unlimited
budget which clearly you'll never have
it can can can this get how good how
good you know what does it what's the
what's the physics
we can get so much more that's work
that's what we have heard and if you
look at the next level from afar same
because again because the back but there
could be many other things that you can
do and there are many
even more plans now that's we actually
have see something so what are the
limitations for example if you look at
the low frequency part where these are
moving that's from the original the
limitations are really how much we can
separate ourselves from there's two
things you can do with this one is you
can with the spaces right there are
plans to put something please so these
are exactly exactly so you can put
something in space these the past
matters as though has already enough to
business then
the other thing is to go underground
because if you go on about this the
surface of you must under so that's
another thing that is happening
the Japanese effect your cargo is
underground since one of you finish in a
few years the next generation factors
people everything else the USS houseboat
is also going to be underground so
that's one thing I can say for example
now in the middle we have a five level
addition as long as you're here on earth
and that's gravity voice difficult so
for example if you have an earthquake
coming back right and can separate
yourself from moving from the earth
moving but you cannot separate yourself
from the best be changing around the
deflector and that causing the
gravitational force to change at the
site that's it just can't shield against
that so that's sort of a fun mental
condition not just below but that's
something we can work around a fee for
example a measure that's a great detail
and council so there's many things you
can do I would say at all courts people
we'll plan for it dancing telescope
everything is again a factor can better
that sort of leg up a good song good
numbers of thinking balance so there's
what we can do
I just had a question so with like that
we can sort of see things that we can
actually observe so I'm wondering like
what place do you guys have and like the
search or the understanding of dark
matter in our universe because of the
Texas characteristics we are scented the
things that's basically T shape with
roughly one second but around this
hundred Hertz that we are seeing now
what did it for you need something
that's extremely compact and roughly the
size of the Sun or three times bigger if
you have something much bigger like a
Superman survival they're going to move
they're gonna accelerate much slower so
they're gonna not remove enough per
second to for us the people to detector
so we have sort of this sweet spot if
you think that Dark Matter there's lots
of them out there however the change is
going to be unfortunately way below the
sort of frequency range that before
suspect is not enough for us that's why
we're looking for things our platform
where that's not that Xfinity contact
you're a little too much so well working
progress I was thank you so the
signal-to-noise for this event seems
hi so I'm wondering if this event could
have been detected before the like Oh
upgrade yeah very good question so we
improved the factor three roughly so if
you divide 24 by to me that would be
doesn't be but before the Azusa that
stops me again we have to improve a lot
more sense that lower frequencies so in
fact it wouldn't just be the factory
would have been much more at the
horrible now but let's assume does this
factor three again just a disclaimer it
wouldn't it would be a much bigger
difference but can't do the factor three
okay that would be SNR 6s mr6 we don't
know as an r8 we don't claim the
connection for that refresher right so
that would maybe come a little too small
what happened potential dangerous thing
but we would have not published the
discovery on it unfortunately or
actually so it's more like but let me
not to say that if you if you take some
some data and you say that to detect
something with an estimate of this the
process from this information the
probability that you see nothing else
which is smaller is only ten percent so
it's it's sort of is promising this was
very special for us but again
unfortunately British libel this is not
this is not a case one maybe extra piece
of information for advanced level in
dispersed science knowledge was
three months long the amount of day of
the month evolving with pros with this
detector is 10 times more then
everything else combined before all the
stats from before so this is not just
Wi-Fi to say this is you know actually a
huge improvement has been made in your
sensitivity curves there are a lot of
spikes are those like harmonics make
changes in the detective these are
generator bronze which we see a showing
up at a given frequency we start making
changes and see what makes sense to
disappear
sometimes it's not natural spy but
sometimes if it's very big day for
example becomes a label on the
sensitivity curve a little bit being
pushed off especially a new given see
because
they weren't good for to do trees and
then we figured so let me just add them
if you look at the oval or area you know
to stomach that who cares right there
was this little line there um there's
one there's one issue though which was
sort of interesting for events like if
you look at the crab pulsar it's it's
very close to sixty Hertz which is a
huge problem in the US operations right
so European partners did not have this
but in the US if they're having
something which emits things that 60
Hertz is not good because everything is
soon as well the washing machines are at
60 Hertz right so that was actually a
huge problem for us and because of this
for next level we adopted really DC
power supply for this one specific
source so that we can get rid of that
one line and the harmonics well keeping
the rest which don't have sort of
Astrophysical right there so the lines
can be problematic if you really have
something right there but for the most
part we don't really care but I guess
they have they actually I mean you're
talking about removing them to see more
signal but presumably that they contain
a lot of information that structure of
the earth no you mean yeah yeah always
the same position so unless you have a
specific signal that's a Thursday
frequency it's not gonna be important if
it's exactly that frequency you are in
trouble for another way around
use the Speights to learn something
about the earth is what I'm asking not
remove the spikes to learn about it yeah
presumably they're not it's not seismic
resonances yet it's really about a
spectacle let me just say that it's the
same 44 right if we if you can measure
I'm connectivity a defector we're not in
good job our goal is to not be able to
do that to separate our detectors enough
so that that doesn't appear in our data
so if it if it works we would not do a
good job basically so we're you know but
okay I can think about this but so now
that one of those guys is first base
their goal detector internal earth this
lure frequency
thank you I just want to ask about the
masses my understanding is that 30 solar
mass black holes are a little heavier
than we expect from stellar evolution
models yes and I guess so there's the
there's the sort of stellar astrophysics
question there which I haven't actually
posed and then the other thing which is
somehow related to that in my mind is
that because the GR is scale free there
must be some Colbert there must be some
degeneracy between the Doppler shift of
the system relative to us and the total
mass of the system there must mean you
must be able to change the Doppler shift
to change the total mass so that is the
cosmological world model coming in there
or something is there some way we could
systematically move questions the first
is again the first part of the question
was that this is a very heavy black ball
against 30 times the mass of the Sun and
typically we don't expect such a black
hole from from different sources we have
not seen these kind of black but this
kind of scale if you look at typically
what people consider it in different
models of how stars evolving for black
holes we typically expect that was cut
off much earlier to not produce these
large black holes
now there's an observational bias right
it's harder to detect these big things
but basically the sort of trends in the
field
that's how people think it starts or how
people understand how big back was our
fourth is really there's a lot of micro
physics our goal but we don't understand
this point and if you look at the trend
basically how big the black holes can
get depends on how much mass the Stars
lose before they collapse into a black
hole and this is where our understanding
will it changed even in the past few
years there's a lot of uncertainty
because we cannot derive these numbers
from first principles but if you look at
before the Dutchman now what's gonna
happen is a whole different question but
before the deduction what people were
trying towards this to introduce models
where the starts to lose less mass of
stellar winds are less importance and so
the black holes can grow bigger so if
you take everything but year ago it's
not that surprising anymore that this
can happen but again we are in the dark
to some extent for example if you want
to have bigger stars you have to go back
in time so you have less metallicity
which is more typical not at our
environment but farther away but we
don't we don't really see stars that far
unfortunately so we have to extrapolate
based on what we see there's lots of
uncertainties involved but again the
trend was even before their stats this
is going to be possible and now I think
it's gonna accelerate even further the
second part of the question can I say
there are additional papers if you go to
line go to work yes so actually both of
your questions got a separate paper on
it so excellent questions yeah and
there's many I think there's roughly 10
different papers again you got two of
they're a good question the second
question is again very good so we have
an ascertain see if it's something is
farther right you on its right shifted
you will see just a lower a slower
motion why is that how can we
differentiate between something that's
on that just lower as opposed to just a
something that that's actually bigger
right or actually closer and there's a
so in principle that's a good question
there are different things we can put
together to understand on which that's
basically to break the degeneracy in
this case if you look at the specs
revolution right that's where you can
have
such a redshift but for example if you
use basically three pieces of
information you use there's a special
evolution at the early phase when there
is a really distance or until you look
at the later part of the evolution where
you really form a black hole and you
look at the the brightness basically how
strongest source was this is enough
information to to basically derive the
actual distance now the one uncertainty
and server before just what a certain
time having the results the distance
this if you look at the actual distance
there's a large uncertainty there yeah
anyway so there's a 410 there's a large
uncertainty there and that uncertainty
is not because of this so this is not
really the source of the uncertainty
uncertainty is really that's we cannot
tell what direction of the orbit
happiness so is the inclination of the
orbit is the main source of this
uncertainty that you see there we cannot
resolve that uncertainty but that's not
that's not a distance okay good so let
me just slightly rephrase the question
does that mean that this system alone
provides a point in the distance
redshift relation or there are there are
papers in there so that in principle the
answer is yes the problem is that the
uncertainties are still large enough
such that you cannot provoke from one
measurement you cannot really have
anything meaningful in this term but in
principle if you had and that's an
excellent question if you had many of
these observations then you could really
do what you're suggesting it could
really use this as sort of an extra
measurement for the evolution of the
universe so that's something that people
are proposing there are many articles is
not in this 10 articles but there are
many articles on that again you need
multiple measurements of this but you
know it's a very interesting direction
good question thank you I'm sure this is
discussed in the papers too but I just
wanted to ask about constraints you have
an electromagnetic counterpart so how
rapidly were you able to constrain the
localized part of the sky that is might
have happened on and how rapidly do you
actually trigger follow-up object
that's something we have a slide on that
yeah sure sure peaceful on the slide
yeah that's a clean so basically yeah
just what I wanted to slice there um
there's two things the first is as we
mentioned after three minutes after the
dissidents they're right other sites
we've recovered the signal we recovered
this is an event so I would say order of
minutes we already know that this is
significant and we brought in another
direction we sort of refined the
direction directional distribution later
on this is a plot from our paper so
that's that that's so that's the sofa
that's fine that's a so-called sky map
that's the area on the sky that we
recovered so basically something like
this not as precise but order magnitude
this precise is really recovered within
minutes very quickly
well not quickly for a gamma-ray burst
for example but very quickly for many
other photos so that's a time frame and
so when we talk to on electromagnetic
partners that we talk to neutrino
telescopes we really can be talking
about this time frame for the precision
well you see roughly what the precision
is now two things to note here the first
thing is that right now we have two
detectors or two like those sites next
year in the next science run we're gonna
have at least we're going more and then
but maybe two more detectors within the
decade so that will bring down this huge
region a lot so it's gotta be much
smaller right now what you're looking at
is 600 square degrees it's difficult
it's challenging but for some telescopes
so it's a special effort to look over
this whole area so did you look at
previous all-sky survey data from
rosette or Fermi or other things to see
if there happened to be some interesting
so it's not like previous what people
did before what we have is a set up
program where we send out these signals
to partner yeah no no I understand I
just meant that I mean this is a very
large region of sky so obviously you
can't trigger immediate follow-up at 600
square degrees but their current all Sky
Survey data sets that exist look and see
if there was something there
for the very good so it's a whole
different direction
research direction how you can actually
find counterparts for these events
there's two things you can do the one
thing is you can look at something which
has a large magnetic or neutrino for
example that has a very large field of
view itself so if you have a gamma-ray
burst for example that will be detected
practically over the whole sky anyway so
you don't really need to look in
distraction if you have something like
an optical counter product you looking
for it
you really have to scan through this
area especially if you have a small feel
of you and that takes time fortunately
there are predictions that there are
canta parts for example for a binary
neutron star merger that will last for
days so you will have enough time to
actually look through this area and this
is what we're doing so fortunately even
though you have a small philia but
typically you will have enough time you
have days for optical you have years for
radio for example to scan through this
area this is again something you're very
actively working on to optimize this
process neutrinos are also all-sky so
what you're seeing here all the
neutrinos are detected at the same time
we don't need to look in any direction
excellent question thank you yeah Emre
just I mean this is this requires a long
answer to some extent but if you look at
your inferred rate it's pretty high yeah
something like maybe 0.1% of the
supernova rate in the universe is what
you're seeing for the inferred rate of
these mergers and so it could point to
these being in some special location
within the galaxy in which has I've been
thinking about that and yeah very good
very good so what can we say beyond the
fact that this is you know how often
it's happening and let me add one extra
piece of information is really the size
of these zone of these black holes that
was one of the previous questions how
can they grow this big and one of the
things we know for sure is that for them
to grow this big the metallicity of the
area where they are has to be fairly low
it's basically our constraint is below
1/2 the solar medal but likely or
possibly even lower so to that extent we
can say things like this now another
piece of evidence we can say for example
do we see any eccentricity in the in a
signal can we tell whether this was the
two black holes dynamically merging
dynamically just meeting in some
environment with lots of black holes or
they possibly fought together now we
have not seen any a meaningful
eccentricity so it is more likely
that's the black holes formed a binary
long before they actually merged so that
also is limiting on where the specific
thing is so there are many things you
can add to this picture on on where they
form now the other thing to notice in
terms of the formation mechanism is that
the two masses are fairly similar so
that's also potentially meaningful in
terms of what the what the process was
that created this thing so there were
specific options proposed of why this
specifically is the case which may not
happen in every scenario so we do have
something ditches I don't think this is
a we have a final word on this there's
many uncertainties the good news is that
the high rate also means we'll have many
more detections very soon so we can we
can tell much more about that soon so I
noticed in the fact sheet so you have an
upper bound on the gravity of mass so
I'm sure this is not the priority in
this experiment and everything so but I
cannot help myself from asking so yeah
yes 10 to the minus 22 yeah so if you
look at yeah so the priority just two
questions about it so is it derived in a
more-or-less model independent way and
do you think that with the improvements
in the future you could lower this
significantly um this is um this is
model independence and if you look at
how this compares to other measurements
that are out there this is better than
model independence estimates we had
before but it's worse than model
dependent estimates we had already from
from galaxy clusters so depending on
your taste you can call this the best or
not the best but you can definitely
improve on this a lot let me just say
two things first of all if you have
multiple detections it's going to
improve this number is gonna improve
with that if you have an actual in the
counterpart you can potentially improve
this as well so this number will
definitely go down as we go on
and again we don't really use any model
medicine so it's fairly straightforward
okay so we can expect lower orders of
magnitude like to be lowered
significantly
I wouldn't say you know whether it's
orders minor - it's hard to say but it's
you know as we have more data we
definitely will improve this on quite a
bit okay thank you thank you
hey I have a naive question about
latency ya know this counterpart
business what really matters is how fast
you actually discovered the same so if
somebody watching the screen all the
time and did you actually find it as it
was happening or it was this the next
morning is it oh my god what is it
yeah very good so so what was the
latency or how fast we go from okay well
the doctors back is something to do hey
let's let's open a bottle of champagne
and I would say this is a long process
for many reasons especially for this
specific event and the one thing I would
want to emphasize here is that again
since this is the first section of this
kind and since we have no way to produce
a gravitational wave detector detectors
we wanted to collect extraordinary
evidence to make sure that nothing goes
wrong right so we will that everything
besides aliens that could produce this
signal so that was a long effort than
the reason we took this long from
September to today is really to make
sure that all these things are accounted
for now this will not be repeated every
time you detect something I hope at
least right so it's gonna go way faster
in the future but let me let me add
another aspect and that's related to the
fact that this was an engineering run
right after we turn on the detector what
happens is as you turn on you really
have no way to characterize your
sensitivity characterize your data
what's happening is our background is
not Gaussian it's something slightly
more complicated we have so-called non
Gaussian transients so in order for us
to understand how sensitive something is
we have to collect more data that's why
it was very important what you dimension
to keep the detector configuration on
after this this observation so the three
minutes detection or a sort of trigger
that we found had no way to tell what
the actual significance was that first
trigger was only saying hey this is
interesting you should look more if you
looked at the data it looked like hey I
can see with my eye you know you can
sort of tell but
the five Sigma that we have you cannot
tell that right away so that takes
longer now if you have a longer
observation rod and you detect something
in the middle you will have a much
better way to tell right away what is
happening but this was again not the
case here so this made our lives a
little harder in their sense but again
as we understand it effects are better
right this is also the first answer on
four for advanced LIGO so we had really
no idea what to expect it really took a
lot of effort to get to the point where
we understand it but this is not gonna
be the case forever we're gonna do this
way faster on all sides so I expect much
less latency in this case definitely not
before publication signals get even
bigger and really this one was so huge
that on the day of the event I mean yeah
NASA flying I really went online and I
was looking for the so-called Oh
micrograms and I've seen this okay this
may be a bit Polish in there it's paper
but I've seen it it was there and I said
wow this is it okay so it was there we
knew we had the infrastructure to send
things out and we are sending them out
to partners we were very slow on that
first event because they were not they
were not even expecting god it was the
engineer on so I I really think this can
be much faster and in terms of data
analysis it's already there it's it's
convincing you guys we are sending real
data and the big bonds it's gonna be
quick don't tell me 30 seconds we are
never gonna do that okay yeah I would
argue with that but we'll see we'll see
um but let me let me add that one of
them thousands of channels that we have
with respect to seeing what happens is
is Gmail so um if you look at what you
know even if you didn't look at this
these there's plots afterwards in the
last you know half a year it's there is
there has been some
data there there has been some extra
signal there I had a colleague who's
complaining that his Department
contacted him because they thought he
had a virus because produced 50 percent
of the department's email influx so it
was difficult thing just to delete
whatever was not important so there you
know it was fairly clear that there had
to be something but in terms of you know
making this rigours there was a lot of
checks that we had to do let me also add
just because of the timing things so
again we're talking about three minutes
but technically imagine you have this
kind of signal and you have something
with - if against this merger when you
enter fully the sensitivity BAM
here we started off at 35 first that was
the lowest signal we could detect but
we'll go down to 10 Hertz eventually and
within this time frame
you really have minutes that attacker
spends or the the signal spends with in
the detector sensitive bands and within
minutes if you have high enough
sensitivity you can imprison tell that
there is a signal before it actually
emerged so there is a chance that we can
actually not just go to you know 30
seconds but actually go before and
predict that something will happen in a
minute or so again not currently but
this is something in a foreseeable
future so the line of sight the
orientation with respect to the plane of
emerging black holes
how do you determine that yeah very good
so basically we have searched I can you
go to the yard
you're just light on this there's a
slide on on orientation versus distance
basically again of you have you have a
waveform information the the problem is
that if you are really perpendicular the
the plane is perpendicular to the line
of sight then you know it's it's a
linear polarization you see there
directly but if there's any other angle
basically we have a really hard time
saying if it's really on really faced on
it's really just close to that so that
extends yeah here so basically there's
this ambiguity between orientation on
the x axis here and Vista so basically
in if you are faced on you radiate
towards the earth and a case 50% more
gravitational waves and if you are on
some average
a direction because again there's little
information in the polarization unless
you're really perpendicular it's very
hard to decouple these these different
effects so as you see there is a huge
answer that's the biggest uncertainty in
our in our distance range if we have
something electromagnetic it would be
much simpler we didn't you know for
black holes that's not something you
expect
unfortunately so this will remain for
most parts again it's very hard to
resolve this if we'll have more
detectors that can help as well but it's
it's that's one of the difficult
questions we face experimental you have
to be a couple these two things if you
have a good very good
quick question to what extent will like
I be able to constrain the number of
polarization modes that you see in these
will you be able to constrain the number
of polarization modes in your signals
it's an excellent question and it would
be great to what to find that something
is very different the problem is for
other polarization modes we are way less
sensitive then for the mean one so if
there's anything slightly different than
what we expect additionally the signal
that we expect from that will be will
have to be way stronger than what we did
that occur so in principle that's
possible in principle we can do many
things like that in practice is
extremely hard because we need much
higher signal-to-noise ratio than for
these events so I would say that the
main way we can test things beyond
general tivity is is a slightly
different we can really and one of the
things there is a separate paper on this
was one of the many papers how we can
test the general relativity with what we
observed and what are the tests for
example that we had is to look at
different parts of the wafer can you go
back to the basically if you look at the
the initial part is so-called in spiral
part when you on when you see the two
black holes still yeah the previous yeah
the feeder than previous one the two so
the left side of here when you see the
two black holes still separates coming
together you can use this information
basically to
recover the the parameters the Blackwell
parameters for example the masses from
this you can predict what you expect at
the end and then separately you can
reconstruct what happened before from
the very last for the so-called ring
down Portland well Blackwell forms and
it's physically losing energy
so from these two parts you can visit
the recover information about the two
black holes independently and then you
can compare these two measurements and
there's any sort of hair if there's any
problem with general relativity this is
one way to test the consistency this is
what we did fortunately or unfortunately
it's up to you we found no discrepancy
from general activity so there are many
different tests for different
polarizations for extra most it's a
little more difficult experimentally
expect us for these that was it's
actually the sweet spot spot for the
detector expectancy range so this is
close to the the size the Blackwell
masses that we can see at the Fortis
distance so that's that's a lucky thing
actually for us that's what you expect
right you're gonna expect to see the
thing that you see the farthest um the
question about the detector um you know
what configuration it was in when it
made the discovery dual recycling
resinous I've an extraction broadband
what configuration detector was in when
we made a discovery
these are getting ready for the first
science run operational run recorder in
advance I go so basically everything was
ready but they were testing at that
point where some of the online code
which would be used to send
for example signals we had one of the
online food running the first hood for
the CBC codes we only had a small mass
code running they were waiting for the
highness code and it was still not
approved it wasn't running so the first
code detected the signal first and then
we had like two three weeks of waiting
until they have the detector data at the
same configuration with which we froze
and then we had the Box opening event
online with like only we're hoping for
that big spot which you can see on the
resident right side top right side on
one of our figures at several of our
figures in BC BC deep analysis so we
really froze the detector let me add one
more point one thing which is very
important for the data analysis to have
some sort of calibration already and we
were actually doing pretty great at that
phone we had a very good friend luminary
Commission so we understood what we are
measuring what strain that is we had a
very good understanding they were doing
calibration runs quite before that time
and they beep already and it's very
important part and people really nearly
ready they were what they were doing is
really just testing out the code so not
much changed after we collected enough
data which was published and we went
ahead with the rest of the science fund
the changes were totally minimal yeah I
would just add that small changes are
being made even though even throughout
science runs so it's not something
that's a hundred percent affects we
tweaked small things to account for
things we discover without really
touching the details so so these kind of
changes are completely normal
even within science runs yes exactly I
mean we can have a little seismic
problem and you know northway coming
which is a bit bigger and then something
yet so what we have to put it back to
lock it again we can have their windy
day so I mean configuration was the same
for
many weeks and we were looking very
nicely most of the time we needed a long
long long stretch of data regulations on
the result if advanced further would
have been running how much better would
the localization would have been and can
you comment us on the status of or
prospects for LIGO India yeah very good
so for advanced Virgo it's also
depending on on what stage you are in so
if you look at how advanced Virgo will
advance throughout the next three or
four years while we get to design
sensitivity it's gonna be again one year
behind light was there's gonna be
slightly less sense there so there are
aspects but if you just assume the first
year what what they're gonna have very
soon there would be a huge improvement
so you're talking about the four factor
of ten or more it would it would make a
big difference to have a third detector
if you have four it's not an extra
factor of ten but it's still it's still
meaningful again as you saw like India
at this point is plans so it's not under
construction but if it happens it's
gonna be very nice let me add something
about there go turning on and can we use
that yes you know it says that they said
that it will not have sensitivity what
we will have and but that's okay at the
beginning even at the beginning if we
have a few dropping signal which is huge
in like oh and they are not that that
sensitivity there they are likely to
have it in there sort of very not very
high as in our triggers and we can
definitely use their data to have a lot
lot better on the on the direction of
the event it's gonna be really really
great and we're gonna start joining us
even if they are not there where we are
the dates are really important for for
localization
I so it looks like looking back at the
binary black hole system itself the fits
you have to the waveform are from a
quasi circular orbit so are there any
limits on the SN tricity of the orbit
which I'm sorry which so of the binary
black hole orbit are there any limits
and what the Essen tricity of that well
again that's an ambiguity right so it's
yes works decoupled so sorry what was
the under question whether we have
whether we test the like what the
inclination is no I just wondered it
that's a orbital parameter of the system
the a centricity of the orbit and in
spiral I just wondered if there's a
limit on that cuz I don't see anything
in there yeah if there was a limit on
the inclination right can you go to the
inclination there is a limit it's it's
it's really hard to be couple that from
the distance right so the two are and
they give to the largest I'm not even a
hundred percent no no each one just go
forward no the one that's a clinician
degenerate as the previous one yeah
thank you right orientation right so
it's a parameter but it's extremely hard
to be a couple that from the distance
okay so the two can have overlapping
circulation of the orbit okay maybe
doesn't have a separate sorry okay
misunderstood your question
we do have a limit on eccentricity yes
apparently it's like 0.1 or something
it's a fairly strict limit so we know
it's not it was not a dynamical dynamic
so in that sense it's on it's a fairly
good limit so it looks like it was a
binary there for a long time yeah so
that's definitely a parameter that's
what we're looking for and again if
there was a nest reduced even it would
be even more interesting unfortunately
so if there was a very highest in her
City would it be would you be detecting
these systems that so we look for us to
just be very important again that's one
of the differentiators between different
evolutionary models so it's very
important for us to see that again many
of us origin in dynamic
mergers in different places so we would
be very happy with mr. Justine not this
time yeah yeah definitely so yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure code by diverse
searching oh yeah huge yeah so for this
specific scene that wouldn't matter if
it's not a too big exid really wouldn't
matter um but we detect those things as
well so long in this sense it's not an
issue of course if you have a mash
filter that does not incorporate that in
the search but your sensitivity is
slightly less but it's not an issue we
would see those as well and again for
these things you can actually limit the
eccentricity and maybe that to the fact
sheet I guess I thought it funny yeah
somehow God wasn't there guess no more
space okay well thank you very much guys
for coming
go we made this bat urine half ago right
in the summer so thank you I'm so
delighted that I won the bad but I'm
organized it about watch coming